ok j'ai un petit problème pour vous
imaginez qu'on vous donne deux lettres
et dans chaque lettre vous savez qu'il
ya un montant est l'une des lettres
contient le double du montant de l'autre
donc l'autre contient la moitié de leurs
besoins et vous devez choisir au hasard
une de ces deux lettres
imaginons vous preniez celle là au
hasard si vous prenez cette lettre au
hasard vous ouvrez et là vous apprenez
que vous gagnez 2 euros question
maintenant que vous avez ça je vous
offre la possibilité de d'échangés de
passer à cette lettre donc d'échangés de
lettres
la question c'est qu'est ce que vous
faites est ce que vous changez de
lettres ou est-ce que vous gardez vos 2
euros je vous invite à y réfléchir et à
mettre vos réflexions en commentaire et
on en reparle la prochaine fois